a boat full of creepy creatures from RL
Stein's Goosebumps books are brought to
life on the big screen in the movie
goosebumps which stars Jack Black as the
famous horror writer I'm John and this
is 10 things you probably didn't know
about goosebumps to bring the movies
zombie like ghouls to life eight actors
had custom made flesh coloured
prosthetics applied to their faces the
ghoulish face prosthetics were made from
medical grade silicone each set of
prosthetics took a whole day to make and
the actors playing the goals each needed
a new set applied every day as for the
ghouls long fingers 1500 of those are
made by hand then hand painted and
brushed with clear nail polish
unlike the facial prosthetics each
prosthetic finger could be used three
times from getting their prosthetics
applied to dressing and hand tailored
vintage clothes it took each ghoul three
and a half hours to get ready several of
the actors playing the ghouls already
had plenty of experience playing zombies
as they'd worked on the TV show The
Walking Dead if you're wondering what
the hair department used to make
professor shocks hair stand up on end it
was actually laundry detergent to bring
to life slappy the dummy are else teens
also ego in the movie a ventriloquist's
dummy was made by Californian effects
firm iron head studio whose creature and
costume design has featured in The
Avengers Godzilla and the hunger games
mockingjay director rob letterman wanted
Slappy's face to resemble Jack Black in
the movie as black plays RL Stein and
also does Slappy's voice onset puppeteer
Avery L Jones controlled Slappy's
movements and scenes where slappy walks
were later enhanced with computerized
effects according to young stars Dylan
Manette a day a rush and Ryan Lee the
movie's creepiest character was the
clown especially because the actor
playing him never broke character on set
to turn performer Vivian Kyle into the
snake lady it took around three hours
which included applying face and chest
prosthetics airbrushing her hands and
fitting her skin tight metallic dress
the snake lady's eyes were made from
polarized sunglasses and could be popped
out easily during breaks in film
as for her wig that took three people 90
hours to make the Bob monster who's
known as the swamp monster in author RL
Stein's books was a late addition to the
movie creature special effects designer
Stephen Prouty created the costume by
hand sewing thread that's used for
camouflage hunting uniforms onto fabric
netting actin 800 a who played the bog
monster in real life is married to
Vivian Kyle who plays the snake lady the
Egyptian priestesses eyebrows are made
up of hieroglyphics which spell the word
goosebumps the isolator wigs worn by the
movies frozen people were made by
painting wigs with white and clear Kohl
King or sealant from a hardware store it
took four weeks to create 14 wigs which
match the actors own hairstyles as to
the icicles that hang from the frozen
people's faces they were made using
clear acrylic and vacuum-formed plastic
although the movies were Woolf is a
computer-generated creation rather than
a practical effect a stunt performer
acted out some of its moves to give the
filmmaker the point of reference for how
the creature might act according to
visual effects supervisor Eric Nord be
the most difficult creature to create
was an evil poodle which only appears in
six shots in the movie the reason it was
so challenging is that it's extremely
tough to make it's tightly coiled fur
look real in CGI in fact it took the
visual effects team four to five months
to perfect its appearance now let me
know in the comments below who are your
favorite characters in goosebumps and
which your favorite books in the series
if you enjoyed this video do please
share it hit the thumbs-up button and
subscribe for loads more things you
didn't know as well as movie reviews and
interviews
thanks for watching and see you next
time you'll be going movie lovers
you